I feel like I've seen shockingly little
talk around the internet about the fact
that DC Suicide Squad is getting a
proper seemingly well-made anime so
what's happening like this Suicide Squad
isekai just got a trailer recently and
it actually looks pretty damn good the
only time I've really seen this whole
show discussed online was people
complaining about the Joker design and
like yeah that's kind of fair but the
rest of it does look pretty damn well
made from what I've seen and again I
can't stress this enough we are actually
getting a show where Harley Quinn and
king shark are transported to a mystical
anime world and get to cause all sorts
of Chaos in there I mean come on if
that's not fun I don't know what is